Home Secretary pretty Patel was asked if
she'd apologize to health workers and
their families I'm sorry if people feel
that there have been failings I'll be
very very clear about that but at the
same time we are in an unprecedented
global health pandemic right now it is
inevitable that the demand and the
pressures on PPE and the demand for PPE
are going to be exponential they're
going to be incredibly high and of
course we are trying to address that as
a government and I think that is right
that is our priority let's go live now
to Nadine barber he's in London it
doesn't seem like that apology has made
the situation any better does it so I
don't think it has they're commentators
across the board you know from from
broadcasters even to government
supporting newspapers who've been very
harsh in their analysis of that daily
briefing on Saturday with the Home
Secretary who hadn't been seen in public
for some time actually so lots of
attention particularly on that event and
the the feeling is that her message was
I'm saying sorry that people are feeling
that way twice she was pushed to
actually apologize to the families of
health workers who've died after
contracting coronavirus now on Saturday
their health secretary Matt Hancock
sorry on Friday the health secretary
Matt Hancock did say that he would start
an inquiry into the deaths of the many
NHS nurses and doctors and health
workers who've died it could be as many
as 28 according to some counts but that
was to see if they had contracted the
virus at work rather than failures and
whether it was the lack of protective
equipment which contributed to their
deaths as many families are saying so in
that context and also in the context of
mr. Hancock saying that health workers
should use equipment sparingly which
also went down very badly with people in
the NHS if you look at social media that
was the context in which pretty Patel's
know
apology if you like has been received
and it all does add up to a growing
surge of demand from within the system
and outside for really getting a grip on
the problem now of course on Friday the
UK says it took her it received a
shipment of two hundred and fifty
thousand individual items of protective
equipment from Turkey they though have
to get distributed around the country
and to the right places so pretty Patel
did say the government was doing all it
can perhaps they are now in terms of
moving the equipment around but in terms
of actually messaging I think they're
not going down very well and the deme in
Russia we've had a sharp rise in the
number of cases is that the result of
more testing and better detection or of
a real sudden surge in the virus no
siree I think it's I think it's more the
latter I think that already the Kremlin
has admitted that there is increasing
pressure on hospitals both in Moscow and
in some petersburg as the number of
cases Rises now the death toll in Russia
is still relatively low it's risen in 24
hours by 129 to a total sorry I'll give
you that again that was that was
incorrect
the the the number of deaths have risen
by 24 up to 130 but it's this rise in
cases in 24 hours almost rising by a
third to take it to 2,000 186 cases
confirmed
kovat 19 cases in Russia the real figure
as in other countries could be larger
with people actually dying in the
community rather than in a hospital but
the the Kremlin is admitting that there
is an increasing problem so far
President Putin has delegated a
responsibility to other people he hasn't
been giving these daily briefings for
example but there is an admission
there's a problem it's in sharp contrast
to places like Germany where in fact
there have there have been many more
cases but a comparatively low death toll
the death toll in Germany just rising in
24 hours by 129
compared to that figure in Britain which
was almost a thousand and the reason
that there but people think that solo is
because of testing which has happened in
the weeks leading up to now testing and
contact tracing now the government in
Britain is saying that they will get
better at doing that they have well
they're their scientific advisors have
admitted that they could have learned
lessons from Germany earlier on they say
they're getting better at it but so far
the testing target of for Britain is a
hundred thousand per day at the end of
this month we're less than twenty
thousand a day at the moment so a lot of
catching up to do indeed let's thank
Nadine Barba vet from London